all right so today is the last day of  early voting and one valley woman voted  for the first time in over two  decades her name is dorothy osborne and  she  is 96 years young she lived here in las  vegas for 54 years and because of the  pandemic she's  mostly stayed in her home but today she  was adamant she had to get out there and  vote  so she paid a visit to her local polling  place her granddaughter brought her over  and her reasoning was pretty simple  because i want the right guy to get in  she was the right guy to get in osborne  says she likes to stay on top of  politics and felt that this year  was one of the most important election  years to vote so  way to go dorothy she's a sweet lady i  like her